One of the fastest growing
areas here in Waimakariri
is the northeast, with Woodend,
Ravenswood and of course Pegasus.
We currently rent space here in Pegasus for
community activities, but really, it's too small.
So the Council is proposing to buy land and
build new community centres for these areas.
The Council's preferred option is to buy land and
build a community centre in Pegasus starting next
year, then around 2028 buy land in Ravenswood
and build another community facility there.
Alternatively we could build both facilities
within the next five years or we could build
one large centre to cater for all areas
including woodend and that could be
either here at Ravenswood or at Pegasus.
Visit waimakariri.govt.nz/letstalk to
look at the options and to have your say.